pour cette interview echo Yoann c'est
Bruno millienne député MoDem des
Yvelines et corps co-rapporteurs de la
mission flash sur les mesures
d'accompagnement de la création des aid
fe zone à faible émission ces zones ou
la circulation des véhicules polluants
est limité bonjour Bruno mignonne
bonjour alors depuis début septembre 10
métropoles dont dernièrement Rouen
viennent de mettre en place ces fameuses
aides FFE objectif atteindre 45
métropoles d'ici 2025 en quoi cela
consiste concrètement
concrètement cela consiste à faire
baisser la pollution de l'air là on
parle pas que de gaz à effet de serre il
faut aussi travailler sur les notes et
sur les particules fines et donc l'idée
c'est de faire baisser dans les dans les
métropoles la pollution de l'air de
c'est une mesure de salubrité publique
de santé publique donc voilà après il
faut l'organiser et en tant que député
vous êtes co-rapporteur d'une mission
flash sur les les zones à faible
émission et vous mettez en avant ce
chiffre en 2025 44% de la population
française sera concernée par ses ETFE
dans les métropole de plus de 150 000
habitants alors est-ce que cela veut
dire que conduire en ville sera bientôt
à un luxe réservé à ceux qui ont les
moyens alors c'est bien le problème
parce qu'on s'est aperçoit lors de cette
mission que intrader ce finalement vous
avez pas de problème en général il y a
des transports en commun et vous pouvez
effectivement vous passez assez
facilement votre voiture mais toutes les
toutes les personnes qui sont
périphériques des métropoles et qui
doivent rejoindre pour leur travail ou
pour aller chez le médecin enfin pour
simplement traverser la ZFE elle risque
d'être en difficulté donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a voulu faire cette mission avec
Gérard le seul de manière à faire une
photographie assez exacte de ce qui
autenté où on est et puis d'amener des
solutions pour que ce soit à la fois
socialement et économiquement acceptable
vous pointez aussi du doigt à une autre
conséquence en sociale de cette mesure
car 38% des ménages les plus pauvres ont
un véhicule classé critère 4 ou 5
c'est-à-dire les plus polluants le reste
à charge pour l'achat d'un véhicule
propre et bien trop élevé comment faire
en sorte qu'ils puissent continuer à
[Musique]
sur une durée assez longue et puis je
pense que là maintenant il faut qu'on
travaille avec les collectivités pour
avoir une campagne nationale et bien
expliqué aux gens ce que c'est ce n'est
pas parce que quand les gens savent ils
confondent en plus je vous ai parlé de
gaz à effet de serre ce n'est pas une
lutte contre les gaz à effet de serre
c'est vraiment une lutte contre la
pollution de l'air qui est responsable
de plus de 40 000 décès par an donc
c'est vraiment une question de santé
publique mais ça faut l'expliquer aux
gens il faut surtout arriver à Anse à
faire en sorte mais avec toutes les
mesures qui sont prises de leur faire
comprendre qu'ils ont une alternative à
la voiture pour aller dans les élèves
vous parliez des collectivités
territoriales pour vous il faut il faut
aider les populations les plus en
difficulté aider aussi les collectivités
et comment évidemment élargir l'offre de
transport public alors il y a plusieurs
niveaux vous voyez que les niveaux qui
concernent le rail par exemple si vous
prenez les RER métropolitains tout ça ça
prend du temps ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent et ça prend du temps il y a des
solutions un petit peu plus simples le
covoiturage mais aussi les bus express
moi qui suis en Île-de-France vous avez
la 14 ex par exemple qui fait manque la
défense qui a commencé à un aller-retour
par jour et qui aujourd'hui est un
aller-retour par heure donc ça
fonctionne mais tout ça faut communiquer
il faut faire des des parkings relay
enfin il y a plein de solutions qu'on
propose dans notre rapport il y a des
solutions à court terme ça là faut les
mettre vraiment vite en place et puis
les autres a plus long terme
effectivement vous n'avez pas le choix
parce que ça demande des infrastructures
importantes il y a aussi des disparités
parce que vous vous parliez de ces
transports mais à une agglomération et
une autre c'est ce n'est pas la même
chose absolument vous avez par exemple
dans la métropole de Marseille
les deuxième et troisième arrondissement
qui sont les arrondissements les plus
précaires et qui sont au milieu de la
ZFE qui eux n'ont pas de transport en
commun par exemple il y a enfin trouvé
d'autres solutions pour pour ces gens là
mais c'est pour ça aussi qu'on veut
mettre en place un comité national de
suivi des etse de manière à ce que les
bonnes pratiques soient partagées entre
tous et peut-être créer quand même une
espèce d'harmonisation entre les
différentes et des feux parce que des
fois ça peut poser a pas de problème
quand vous êtes dans un rayon ou les et
des feux sont assez proches les unes des
autres avec des interdictions
différentes là ça peut poser un vrai
problème un portail unique donc merci
Bruno mignonne député MoDem des Yvelines
d'avoir été avec nous pour parler de ces
et des feux sur Europe 1
[Musique]